a lot of you don't know
a lot about my oldest son big round of
applause for trevor everybody
you guys
just got done talking about the whole uh
porn thing
shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is going on okay so
he said you you messed up a little bit
it was 15 that he said it was 14. he was
50. i remember because it was the year
that i went to ambulance i did serve by
the way and thank you
i went and i
visited right before i went to
afghanistan it was during the summer you
guys had actually gone out just for like
a quick trip out of town um i was there
for a couple weeks
jacob had been out of the house
grandma's grandpa had been out of the
house
thought we were like i might as well
jerk off
[Laughter]
did you guys know
i mean
you may know
you may know this you may not know this
back at that time
on his wikipedia page there was only
one child listed
[Applause]
anybody can write your page and i i
didn't even know i had a wikipedia page
until he goes hey man yeah
you know on your wikipedia page i don't
know how you want those he was yeah it
says you only have one kid that goes
[Music]
what the [ __ ] i go who did that he goes
i don't know i go let's fix it you guys
know they're sleeping for a little while
it's funny
this is not [ __ ] funny it's not funny
enough
but every time i would put it up someone
would someone would take it down
[Laughter]
[Music]
and of course that's going to make me
mad because does he just explain i'm
going to start his [ __ ]
career tonight
i was like this is this
this is the perfect golden opportunity
set up
nobody's home
jacob's already been caught looking at
porn
[Music]
this is the greatest golden
opportunities what do i do i i'm an
adult at this time i'm 20 years old so i
i know about itemized bills i got to pay
my own goddamn bills i live out of the
house
that sucks but i have to pay them and i
know
so i know
by ordering the porn off of direct tv
that's going to show up on the bill he's
going to look at that
that wasn't me
and the first thing he's going to do
what happened
so uh yeah that's that's the score
that's five i was pissed because it
wasn't another competing page
but can i take some right now
i'm so glad you weren't or else i would
have never had that joke
[Applause]
all worth it
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air